(hip music)
- We do not tensely touch in public
in an overtly sexual manner.
- Yeah, none of that happens in public.
- In private, you bet.
- I remember there was one time
that I didn't want to make out.
I just wanted a little more elaborate kiss
on a New Year's Eve, and he
just gave me a little peck,
and I was like "Wow, how
disappointing and anticlimactic."
- He'll grab my butt, and that's fine,
but sometimes he'll go inside of my pants,
and we're in public, so I'm like "uhhh."
- I wouldn't really be too comfortable
doing an intimate dance in public.
- Kizomba is an Angolan partner dance
that actually covers an
umbrella of different types
of genres of music and dances.
I would liken it to, like, tango,
as far as it being a walking dance,
but the music is definitely African-based.
It's become really popular
to see kizomba videos
where it's slow and
sensual, and you accentuate
the woman's movements and
her curves and her hips,
which we call the bunda.
Actually moving with each other creates
kind of a unspoken connection,
so that's gonna be my focus today.
Let's get ready to kizomba.
(upbeat music)
Now what I want you to do
is walk to your partner,
and I want you to give them a hug.
- We're used to having
improv chemistry, I guess.
This is more of you just really
have to feel that honest chemistry
but also, at the same
time, remember these moves.
Step these steps.
- [Yaya] Get closer together.
You guys like each other, right?
(group laughs)
Closer, chest, chest contact.
- [Tenn] Get closer.
One, two, three, four, five.
Okay, good, now I'm gonna
have you guys rotate.
So (laughs) rotate partners, yes.
(group laughs)
- [Tenn] Not bulldozing her.
- All the dance I've learned has been
Bollywood and big and expression,
and this was you and
your partner are close,
and it's smaller steps, and it's closer.
(chill music)
- Having the people here,
and then performing the dance
that we just learned, and had to try
to do it well in front of everybody.
That was definitely a test of confidence,
and a confidence builder together.
She might even get a full
kiss next New Year's.
(laughs)
- I felt a channeling energy
between the both of us
as a unit, and that
I've never felt before.
- Yeah, just trying to sync
up with the other person,
when it comes to a dance
that you don't know,
and you're not skilled with.
(audience claps and cheers)
(chill music)
I was able to look you in
the eye for some of it.
- That's true.
- For a lot of it.
- Yeah, we're making progress.
- Something very new, being
that physically close.
I mean, people dance close, but not like
that face-to-face, eye
contact with eye contact,
and it's very new, and I liked it.
- I feel like I trust him
a little bit more now.
It's been three and a half years,
but there's always more
trust that can be built.
(chill music)